good evening members officers and
members of the public and welcome to
this evening's cabinet meeting 12th of
January
foreign
housekeeping notes if the fire alarm is
activated vacate the offices by the
stairs please do not use the lifts
assemble in holy Square on the green
officers will assist you and advise when
it is deemed safe to return to the
chamber
please switch off or turn to silent your
mobile phone
's and do not make or receive calls
while submitted is in progress
please note this meeting is being live
streamed for members of the public the
meeting will also be recorded and will
subsequently be broadcast on the
internet
does anyone intend to film the meeting
following members have asked to speak
under Council rule 20.1
item four counselor Yates item five
councilors Stuart Piper
council's Everett and councilors Yates
item six is counselors Whitehead Everett
and Yates and item seven is councilor
Whitehead are there any other members
that wish to speak
item five please leader counseling
has
swing
uh Council Austin
four five and six please later but I
promise I will be very brief
four five and six okay
the item five please
okay
I think that is everybody chance thank
you
[Applause]
so
we have no apologies for absence this
evening the cabinet is in full flurry
item two is Declarations of interest
does anyone have any interest to declare
in the items of business on the agenda
this evening
no Charles
item three is minutes of previous
meetings to approve the summary of
recommendations and decisions of the
cabinet meeting held on the 15th of
December 2022 a copy is attached to the
agenda pack I propose that we approve
the minutes do I have a secondary
councilor Bob bayford
do members agree
it is a great Charles
so item four the first one of the
councilor Saunders show this evening is
Council tax-based calculations to
introduce councilor David Saunders
thank you leader
so gender item four is council tax base
if you quite brightly say this report
presents the for approval to council the
council tax base for
2023-24 which is increased by 1.74 on
the previous Financial year
the report also recommends maintaining
the existing schemes for local council
tax support and premiums on long-term
empty properties for next year
subject to the passing of the relevant
legislation we're also recommending that
from April 2024 the council introduces a
100 premium on second homes
whilst we value the benefit second home
owners bring to our local economy it is
important the council can raise
appropriate sources of income from our
visitors whilst simultaneously also
helping to prioritize housing for our
own local residents
leader I move the recommendations within
the report
thank you
for 20.1
first I have councilor Yates
thank you chair
um given the state of this council's
finances it is encouraging to see this
Council introduce a new council tax
premium on second homes with second
homes being defined as unoccupied but
furnished this could be introduced in
April 24 2024 and this seems like a
prudent decision to take given the
popular tourist destination we represent
and will allow us to do more in the
future to support our residents it's
also encouraging it is also to be
welcomed that the long-term empty
council tax charges to be kept which is
something labor introduced when it first
became available when we were in control
this is sensible decision to encourage
landlords with long-term empty
properties to use their properties or to
be charged a premium on their tax bill
thank you
thank you Council Yates I didn't detect
a question there but if you'd like to uh
just like to compliment them I'd just
like to thank Council Leakes for his um
comments we work very well together as
Shadow and portfolio holder and
um I'm not embarrassed by collecting
good ideas from the opposition and
pulling them into practice
on that note um I shall call upon cancer
Austin to speak under 20.1 cancer Austin
thank you leader um I would endorse what
councilor Yates said and I wanted to ask
a question are we able to charge more
than the 300 percent rate that we're
proposing and are we able to escalate
any of these charges more quickly or is
that a statutory requirement that we
stick within those figures thank you
I'm told that at the present time we've
gone to the maximum that we can and
obviously we're waiting for legislation
to go through which we believe will give
us the option to adjust accordingly
thank you
thank you there are no more speakers uh
under 20.1 so um
uh the item has been moved do I have a
secondary councilor Bob bayford do
members agree
thank you members so item five
is fees and charges
also to introduce is councilor David
Saunders
thank you leader this report sets out
the proposed fees and charges for 2324
with the detailed fees and charges being
provided within Annex one of the report
due to the hive inflation environment
that we are currently operating in the
council has seen a substantial increase
in its own running costs and the cost of
the services that it provides for our
various residents the council services
are funded from a broader range of
income streams with fees and charges
being just one means of financing
however other sources of income have
reduced or been restricted in recent
years such as income from council tax
and government grants
therefore given these income
restrictions and the need to balance the
budget locally generated sources of
income such as fees and charges are even
more important than ever
it is therefore important that the
council organizes or organizes itself in
ways that maximize maximize that income
whilst balancing this with managing the
impact on our residents and our service
users as such our strategy has been to
apply a broad 10 increase to fees and
charges where possible which is expected
to generate additional income of six
hundred and ten thousand pounds for next
year's budget as well as consideration
by cabinet and officers the proposed
schedule of fees and charges was
carefully reviewed by the cross-party
cabinet Advisory Group at its meetings
on the 6th of October and the 27th of
October last year a number of
recommendations have been made by The
Keg for cabinet's consideration and
where possible these have been reflected
in the proposed fees and charges before
you this evening
leader I move the recommendations within
the report
thank you very much councilor Saunders
um
cancer student
believes here so I will move on to the
next speaker which is um cancer Everett
thank you leader um I'll let counselor
Yates um set out the labor labor group's
position on this part um there's a
technical point I wanted to make and I
and I have had an exchange with Mr
Blundell this afternoon about this and
he was very helpful in explaining it to
me but I do have concerns about it
when we look at the off street parking
Revenue to be raised in the schedule of
fees and charges
um it appears that in every case the
amount to be raised in the next
financial year is the same as was was
due to be raised in The Current
financial year
until we get to Mill Lane where it's
reported that um the expectation for
this year I think was um 100
000 and the expectation for next year is
195 000.
and yet aligning that with the report I
think that's the total increase expected
on uh off street parking in the next
financial year now that struck me as
being a bit strange and clearly not
correct unless something's going on in
the Mill Lane Car Park or around the
middle Lane Car Park that I don't know
about it
um
and I did this I did some boys that
potentially
um the council was underperforming in
terms of terms of its parking Revenue
this year and therefore wasn't
anticipating as much extra revenue from
a 10 increase as perhaps we might like
um and I understand that's the case
but it doesn't seem entirely
satisfactory to me that the figures are
presented in this way with these sums of
money for the car park there perhaps
ought to be some um explanation of this
and clearly The Mill Lane thing isn't
right and reflects something that's gone
on in the past and it just seems to me
that if we're going to make a 10
increase in parking we do need a proper
understanding of what the current
situation is and what the drivers behind
that are because if we're falling short
in terms of our parking Revenue I'd like
to know whether that's because our
parking charges are already too high and
I do understand that Park and revenue is
unpredictable it's unpredictable based
on the weather since we're a tourist
destination and it's also unpredictable
based on the state of the economy and
people's ability to go out and spend
money so we're never going to get to a
position where we can accurately predict
what the parking revenue is going to be
at any given car park any given car park
but I think it would have been helpful
if we could have had more accurate
information in this report and so that
the council can make the right decision
thank you
thank you councilor I'm councilor
Saunders do you have a response
um I'd like to thank Rick for studying
those areas of the
spreadsheet more thoroughly than myself
I confess that I've been concentrating
on the parking strategy which is taking
far too long and hopefully would clear
up some of the anomalies that we
currently face with regards to our own
car Parks Etc
um
can I refer to
Chris behind me to see if he's given an
explanation satisfactory on those those
figures and certainly I've got to know
and that's something that we need to
look at
um certainly before the next um next
week when we go to overview and scrutiny
because no doubt that's going to come up
again so if Chris can come up with an
answer I'd be obliged thank you thank
you councilor and thank you for the
question Council Everett I'm more than
happy to provide some supplementary
information to go to overview Integrity
next Tuesday to help
help the debate and consideration of the
the committee in order to make further
recommendations back to Cabinet in terms
of the numbers as I kind of explained in
our exchange earlier on today there's
been some issues in terms of the coding
on the finance system in terms of where
previous income has been allocated to
specific budget lines Mill Lane itself
probably isn't that unique in the fact
that it's seeing a large increase in
actual income it's just the budgets have
not been loaded in the right place
previously in previous years when we've
seen increases in car park income
they've just been loaded entirely to
to all our car Parks but we only have
individual budget lines for just the
Royal Harbor car park car park and
Ramsgate and Mill Lane and Margate and
then one budget line for all the others
we do obviously have accurate
information that comes out of our
parking system that will tell us the
actual information actual information in
terms of ticketing and income and I'm
more than happy to collate that and
provide that as information further
information in terms of background
information to the committee so that
they can see
what our expectations are in terms of
income in terms of as Council Saunders
rightly said it's and and yourself
Council over it it's difficult to
predict what the income Trends are going
to be there's been lots of factors at
play the pandemic had a significant
impact on car parking levels and we were
rightly compensated by government for a
number of years for all that loss of
income we're still coming out of that in
terms of understanding the impact on
customer behavior in terms of customers
being the users of our car Parks when
we've been looking to set the charges
for fees and charges for car Parks we're
already always sort of primarily minded
and driven it's used upon by um the
impact on traffic management as opposed
to generating Revenue due to the
statutes and the restrictions around
that and we felt that because of the
high inflation rate to maintain the
real-term effects of those charges
that's why they've been increased rather
than to prop up the the revenue budget
or generate any further income but happy
to provide the further information
that's been requested
thank you um
Chris bundell for that explanation
hopefully that goes away towards
um
answering the question but as you say it
can be brought to ons
um
which I'm sure it'll be raised and
debated thoroughly
um also hoping that we build on our
success of attracting more visitors and
visitors to the town and maybe we can
get up there with some sort of income
figure of that sort of amount if we
continue on our successful rate of
attracting visitors to the area
um that has been moved by councilor
David Saunders and I'm looking for a
secondary councilor Jill bayford
oh sorry I'll move I'll swiftly I'm
sorry
I was Miles Away there wasn't I sorry
I sorry I have it was a nice try wasn't
it nice try sorry cancel the Yates to
speak next sorry
it's close thank you Jeff it must be
acknowledged that we are in a high
inflationary environment cost of cost on
it are going up these costs include fuel
electricity and the cost of gas which
have large impacts on how we run this
Council we acknowledge that changes must
be made to ensure we keep a balanced
budget as an example of this the labor
group welcomed the news the fees and
fees are going up for large filming
companies this was an area that labor
highlighted at the fees and charges
working group and we support this
we as a district are still cheaper to
film and than large London councils but
the increase to 1500 a day for large
film sets is to be welcomed
the increases to planning support fees
for major developments is also welcomed
as these companies can absorb those
costs into their larger budgets
one issue that we will argue though is
parking labor made clear the fees and
charges working group they wanted
additional support for residents when it
came to parking this recommendation
though was not taken forward
so it should come as no surprise that we
repeat our requests that the
hard-working residents of thanet do not
have to bear a whopping 10 increase in
parking charges during a cost of living
crisis the times newspapers spotted this
too just yesterday on page seven of the
times they reported that thanet amongst
a few other councils are to increase
parking charges by 10 with the the
article going on to quote the head of
robed policy at the AAA who said
residents could soon votes with their
wheels and decide to avoid Town centers
and shop online
but it will not only affect our
businesses it will mean the thanet
resident with an annual Car Park season
ticket will need to find another 64
pounds more than last year in order to
go about their daily life
has the cost of maintaining car Parks
increase suddenly uh Royal Harbor car
park in Ramsgate is still without lists
has the cost for Council Car Park season
tickets increased by 10 we don't think
so
the fees and charges report states that
full parking review is to be carried out
by April 2024 and the changes will come
into effect then surely it's better to
wait for the outcome of the parking
review rather than increase costs so
dramatically for our residents during a
cost of living crisis before that review
is complete thank you
thank you councilor Gates and you and I
have had discussions on this previously
yes as I said to the previous question I
have been spending a lot of time talking
to officers with regards to the parking
strategy that's um currently
underway and it would be lovely and I
would I would have loved to have got to
a situation where we could come up with
a scheme that gave our residents
preferential treatment with regards to
parking costs Etc but quite frankly if
the parking strategy comes up with the
recommendations and I believe that it
will it will certainly take a long while
and I guess the whole of 2024 to bring
into play and because what we need in
order to do that is we need to get into
a situation where we have a digital
system that gives students the
opportunity of taking advantage of that
digital situation and we are talking to
other authorities other local
authorities with regards to a situation
where perhaps we could take advantage of
the experience that they've had over the
last two years where in fact they do
have a digital
system that gives a benefit to the
residents so we are working on it I take
the point but we need the revenue during
the full coming year and not in the
following year but um
let's carry on with the debate and hope
that we can move it forward and that the
residents can see a situation where we
can give preferential treatment to all
of the residents and maybe those key
workers that you keep reminding me about
have a premium over and above the rest
of the residents thank you
next to speak
to point money Council Austin
um okay
um picking up on uh councilor yates's
Point again and and I'm pleased to hear
Council Saunders say that he's concerned
that the parking review is taking so
long because that's certainly a concern
that we have when you think that
councilor crittenden's successful motion
to propose proposing a parking review
was way back when we were in the Winter
Garden still socially distanced under
covid rules it's it's been a very long
time in in getting anywhere and it feels
that we're sort of in suspended
animation at the moment it I I'm
not sure why there are certain measures
that we couldn't bring in temporarily
and we've talked about key workers here
and I know Council Garner wants to pick
up on that matter but also things like
coach parking you know we've got no
coach parking no formal coach parking in
Ramsgate and all the way along the
seafront we have coaches parked every
summer it seems an opportunity for some
income and some better facilities for
coaches that we we could perhaps pick up
even if it was only temporarily likewise
I know we've had discussions at the CAG
about making better use of the uh unused
areas on round Skate Port short in the
short term for things like campervan
parking or storage we know we've got
waiting lists for storage containers
things like that those those nice areas
are delineated in lilacs that Mike
Humber has shown Us in previous meetings
I know there are plans for them in the
long term but in the short term perhaps
those are things we could be looking at
that wouldn't cut across the parking
strategy but might actually give us a
bit more evidence as to what demand is
for the future that's all thank you
thank you chaos Larson
um yes I am as frustrated as everyone
else with regards to the speed that um
things move in local government but I'm
unfortunately that's the way we are we
do have resource issues
internally as I'm sure we're all aware
of but I'll keep on the case and as soon
as we can get to a situation where we
can introduce a sensible Arrangement
believe you me we will do obviously the
important Harbor is not part of my
portfolio so I can't make too many
suggestions in that direction but I will
talk to the leader for you thank you
thank you
um councilor Saunders I look forward to
that little chat
um councilor Wing next to speak thank
you I sort of pick up on a lot of points
have been previously said I'm really
glad to see that the car park strategy
will start soon and hope we will involve
stakeholders input and that it will also
consider the very nature of our
communities that exist within fanet
we're parking pressures differ on the
coastal strips of course Central Harbor
where I am are absolutely critical and
chronic I've been involved in working
with residents really since I was
elected because alongside rubbish
parking is parking and housing are also
up there and actually some of our
residents come up with some really good
ideas that we're not feeding into that
but they also have concerns and I also
walked my entire world recently and and
developed a highway Improvement plan
what I found was we have serious issue
with parking where we've got whole roads
where but there's no pedestrian there's
no pavement so we have to consider the
knock-on so I think what I'm saying is
you say the primary purpose for setting
fees and charges for car parks and
on-street parking is to add Aid traffic
management and traffic flow I can tell
you in central Harbor we are utterly
failing in that with that regard and if
you're a pedestrian then pedestrian
safety and the use of Pavements on many
roads is not possible if you've got a
disability or you're a parent with with
a child in a push chair or Mobility
Scooter you've also got a problem
so I I think what I'd like to know and
it follows on from what council Everett
said is how have we evidenced the impact
of increasing charges in previous years
on the positive benefit of traffic
management and traffic flow and how did
that inform decision making now what I'd
also like is and do we actually model uh
the positives and the negatives of any
changes in fees and do we actually look
at the adverse effect that it may have
on a number of people visiting business
businesses and also the impact on
Resident parking so Nelson crescent's
got resident parking scheme today there
was 34 empty spaces that that exists all
the way around the year because nobody
wants to pay two pound Thirty an hour to
park there now we can say that's okay
they just don't pay two pound Thirty but
the the impact on residents is everybody
who comes into town tries to cram on the
free parking behind so we have a
situation where residents are negatively
being affected and busy and perhaps cars
are not visiting businesses in our town
centers because it's freeing at Westwood
cross so if we're going to make
decisions and we go into State it's
going to improve traffic flow and
traffic management I'd like to see more
evidence of of that happening based
around increasing our fees and I'd also
like to see a model in or look at the
the other negative or positive effects
it's having for residents further back
or outside of our parking zones thank
you I know it's a long one
that's quite all right I can let you
know that I certainly have a long long
long list which I've got
um headed what if and so that's my what
if list that I get from residents on a
regular basis
um let's not forget that we are talking
about our own off street car parking as
far as the fees and charges the concern
the on-street car parking is of course
managed by ourselves on behalf of KCC
and obviously we all know that the money
goes into the Crim so that's where we
need to look very carefully at what we
do with regards to on-street car parking
so we tend to concentrate on our own off
street car parking I'm sure Chris can
assure me that we do do modeling based
on fees and charges from our own street
car parking I don't partially get
involved in that but no doubt I'm afraid
I must ask Chris and believe that is the
case
um but yeah I mean I'd really like to
get to a situation it really frustrates
me that we have far too much free
parking in thanet and I've said it
before and I'll say it again I don't
know what the answer is unless we put a
a toll bridge at the Watson
but you know it's it you could you could
we could spend all night debating
um the pros and cons of different
methods with regards to parking
um it's a it's a it's a it's a Minefield
as far as
um getting the right solution for our
residents which is my concern
Chris I don't know if you can assure us
that we do do the relevant modeling
thank you councilor Saunders
um in terms of the modeling this is
something that will actually form parts
of the strategy when we're looking at
the increase this year this as I've
mentioned in my response to council
Everett this is about maintaining the
real term impact of the parking charges
if you're looking if you take inflation
of the count the parking charges are
actually staying the same because of
where inflation is in the economy which
allows the impact to stay the same we're
not looking to improve traffic flow
through increasing charges this year
we're looking to maintain the status quo
which is in accordance actually for look
the last couple of years prior to this
we froze parking charges partly because
inflation was a lot lower but equally
because we knew there was a lot less
people going out and driving and using
our car Parks or car parking spaces
because of the pandemic so a part of the
the parking strategy that will be coming
forward members will have access to the
details that will be coming out of all
that that modeling that needs to be done
but at the moment it's largely around
maintaining the existing uh parking
Arrangements we've got in place from a
real terms inflationary impact
thank you Chris I'm
next week um under 20.1 is um counts for
Garner
thank you leader yeah um
a key key worker parking permit scheme
as we mentioned by a couple of people
and I understand it was
discussed and considered
um at the fees and charges cabinet
Advisory Group and not taken forward and
I I'd just like to ask for that decision
to be reconsidered
um I think this could bring a lot of
benefit to some of the um
some of the people who would most
benefit from from help in our community
and I just wondered if that could be
reconsidered maybe with a pilot scheme
where we could work with a couple of
um
care providers in thanet
um and work out how much that would cost
because I'm sure that the benefits to
those key workers would certainly
outweigh
the costs that it might cost us so I
wondered if that could be considered
please thank you very much
thank you Council ages yes we have
looked at it um the current scheme
um requires
um us to designate zones those zones are
associated
um with some form of prohibition
um double yellow lines pay and display
meters Etc
the main complaint that I get from
residents that live in the zones and pay
their their annual fee is that their
parking space is not guaranteed and they
get very frustrated when they drive home
and find that they are actually not able
to park within the zone that their
permit covers them they have to go and
find somewhere else to to park
so there are difficulties with
introducing that Arrangement part of the
strategy that I believe that we want to
introduce a digital strategy would allow
all residents to have the benefit of a
permit of some sort or the other and
that's the way that we've been looking
and that's the way that we hope we can
go along
fine thank you it wasn't quite what I
was I was more asking about care
providers people who carers who
go around various houses to
um to care for people and then but have
to pay their fee every time they arrive
at somebody's yes I could say that we've
had a lot of debate on what designates a
care provider and
um does it involve anyone that works for
the NHS for instance
um and that's something that I've passed
on to the officers looking at the
strategy at the moment we haven't
forgotten it and we'd like to do
something for those care those care
providers but at the moment it's not on
our radar until we get the information
through of how we're going with the um
the actual strategy thank you
just before I come to councilor Byford I
think 151 is asked to come in thank you
chair
um I think when we discuss this at the
fees and charges cabinet advisor group
there were a couple of different angles
that were brought to think Council Yates
may have brought an angle forward in
terms of the key workers issue there's
um the first aspect of it it's very
difficult to Define what a key worker is
if you recall during the pandemic even
um not to belittle the effort they made
but just giving you an example of the
breadth even Supermarket workers were
were identified as key work examples so
we'd need to very carefully to Define
what is inside or outside of that
definition of a key worker I appreciate
for this
um your questions tonight you've given
the example of care workers then we also
need to think about are we talking about
care workers where they're going out and
doing their job if they are doing their
job I'd expect a reasonable employer
would be re reimbursing those employees
for their expenses the same way they
will for mileage they should reimburse
them for any parking costs they incurred
and as councilor Saunders identified
even if you designate an areas available
for key workers it doesn't guarantee the
space this will be available when they
arrive there the other aspect of it is
when we've been looking at do we want to
provide dedicated spaces for key workers
who live in particular areas when I
think that's a more challenging thing to
get to and say for example nurses when
they return from a night shift late at
night to have they got car parking space
available to them when they return home
again just because you identify
something as being a zoned and someone
giving a permit it doesn't guarantee the
space so it's something that can be
looked at in the future as part of our
parking strategy review but at the
moment it's not something that we could
necessarily enforce with any meaningful
impact as part of the fees and charges
process
there's been a lot of discussion
and and there's more discussion because
councilor Bob bafer would like to come
in
my discussion uh leader I mean really
just a comment I mean in fact it's as
people are aware I've been on this
Council quite some time and probably
every year parking is a major debate
point I think you know parking issues
are getting worse there's no doubt about
that you know Everywhere You Go I mean
whether it's infinite outside Planet
parking is a problem but I think one of
the the difficulties is that the parking
problems are different in area to area I
mean the problems in central Ramsgate
are different to the ones in Kingsgate
but they're no less severe and no less
you know sort of troublesome for for
residents and visitors alike
so what I was going to say is not very
positive but I mean we're looking for
this parking review but unless it's
really really comprehensive and it would
need to be
um I think wouldn't hold your breath for
solutions to some of the problems that
we've got being sold by parking charges
alone
thank you uh well I don't think it's any
secret that um I've always
struggled with the thought that probably
than it is the only coastal town in the
whole country that actually doesn't
charge to park on
um the coastal roads
um
but there are we have sort of 18 miles
of it but uh like
um it was pointed out earlier by
um cancer Saunders and the 151 officer
is the on street and off Street two
different things so the only way the the
true benefit Revenue benefit to the
council is our off street parking and
I'm very Mindful and fearful that if we
find a really good solution for our
on-street parking then Kent County
council could well be looking very
closely at nicking it back from us so I
think we we don't we need to to be bear
in mind be be you know be careful what
you wish for is is probably something to
actually Mark there because
um they're a council also struggling to
balance the books probably a hell of a
lot more than than we are so
um the only thing I think we can be
thankful for is that we're not a council
that has totally thrown all of our
Revenue eggs in one basket with parking
because those councils that did do that
during the covid period really really
did suffer and struggle and they'll
probably take a lot longer coming out of
that situation than than we will so I
think we're we've been quite prudent
really with with our parking charges in
comparison with with other councils that
might have depended much more heavily on
their parking Revenue so
it is difficult to balance like the
cabinet member for finances pointed out
um and it's something that we probably
always will struggle with but a
comprehensive review will hopefully
point us in the right direction and we
can rely on the Sciences as opposed to
um our um our own thoughts on it so just
the Roundup I think I'm safe in doing it
this time it has been moved
and I would like a second I think it's
councilor Jill bayford is secondly do
members agree
the next item on the agenda is I can
turn over my page
item six which is the
2023-24 budget and 2023 27 medium term
financial plan to introduce no surprise
here will be councilor David Saunders
thank you leader
I'm very pleased to be able to present a
balanced budget for 2023-24 to the
cabinet this evening
the budget setting process began began
in the summer of 2022 and cabinet and
officers have dedicated a tremendous
amount of time and effort to get the
position or to get to the position that
we are now in my thanks go to all who
have been involved and contributed to
this um process I have to say that the
financial team have worked very very
hard on this and my thanks go to them
for the support that they've given in
all aspects as we've been working our
way through the process despite what may
seem like a lengthy and complicated
complicated process this level of
planning is critical in importance it's
how we continue to deliver the services
that matter to people and protect and
support our most vulnerable residents
this report sets out the cabinet's
recommendation to council for next
year's budget we are recommending to
increase our net spending on local
Services by 3.5 million pounds or 19.6
percent for the budget year
this is a really significant increase
the district council faces the same cost
increases as everyone else on fuel
transport and pay and this has to be
funded inflation is a 40-year high as no
doubt I'll be reminded
and the current economic climate makes
it difficult to protect the future or
predict the future and protect it
in addition to the increased cost of
delivering Services The Wider difficult
economic climate means that demand for
some key Services most notably temporary
accommodation for homeless people is
rising providing a safety net for people
who have nowhere to live is one of the
most important things that we do but it
is a demand-driven and costs are rising
I'm also proud to be presenting a number
of proposals to invest in some of the
council's key Services which make a
difference to our local people
with more spending on priorities such as
improved CCTV the recruitment of five
Coastal enforcement offices and more
money for seaweed collection and Coastal
clean cleansing
despite the fact that inflation is
running at around 10 percent our core
funding has only increased by 5.8
percent whilst the council is only
allowed to increase council tax by a
maximum of three percent
therefore we look to maximize our local
income so that we can improve and
provide quality services for our local
people
we're doing this by maximizing key
income streams by charging for services
which are only used by a limited
proportion of our residents we're also
planning to invest more in the council's
property portfolio with the clear
objective to increase Revenue income the
council has a relatively substantial
Capital program to deliver over the next
four years
through ongoing leveling up fund
projects for both Margate and Ramsgate
and the Margate Town deal These funds
provide the opportunity for significant
investment in two of the districts towns
and the impacts on the budget are set
out in the draft Capital programs for 23
to 27.
finally the proposed increase in council
tax at 7.7 pound 42 per band D
equivalent property represents an
increase of less than 15 Pence a week
for each household
leader I move the recommendations within
the report
I too would like to add our thanks to
the hard work that has gone on in to
this from the finance team it has been a
lengthy and hard process but um I think
it was absolutely well managed this this
year and with a lot of contribution
coming in from all angles so
if uh if um Chris Bondo would like to
pass on our thanks to all of the team
to speak under 20.1 councilor Whitehead
thank you very much leader
firstly I would like to thank all of
those involved in the production of the
budget the budget sessions especially
were very useful and provided a very
positive resource to all members
there is obviously something I very much
welcome in this budget
roughly a year ago I said these words in
this chamber
the conservative budget proposes to use
the 549 000 new homes bonus to pay off
debt
the labor group proposes to amend this
budget allocation
we propose to set aside the remainder of
the new homes bonus to fund the
provision of additional in-house
temporary accommodation
I Then followed this proposal with the
following argument
property values in Margate alone Rose by
14.4 percent last year
they are predicted to rise to that level
again over the coming year
delaying purchases by one year increases
the cost of purchase by an estimated 15
according to predictions
which means that delaying the purchase
of property now costs us an additional
82 350 pounds to buy equivalent property
in a year's time
there is no debt that we could pay down
now that is accruing interest at that
level
the argument is not sound and is the
opposite of fiscal responsibility
politics does not have to be
oppositional
we are at our weakest when it becomes so
because it blinds us to the potential in
ideas and to the good in others
but forward that argument cabinet
overview and scrutiny and Council and my
idea was still rejected in spite of it
being to fiscally sound
since I made that argument property
inflation in Margate has increased by a
further 10 to 24.5 in less than two
years and inflation has increased to 11
percent
an overall likely increase in purchase
and development costs of 24 25.5 in the
last year alone
I thought for months to push for the
usage of last year's new homes bonus for
further in-house temporary accommodation
because I knew that we would be facing
extraordinary pressures in the coming
year
and with an 800 000 pound growth in
paying for private temporary
accommodation I believe I was more than
right to do so
So reading this budget is bittersweet
I welcome wholeheartedly the usage of
this year's new homes bonus towards
further in-house temporary accommodation
and will support councilor Jill bayford
and Cabinet in that in whatever way I
can because I believed it was necessary
then and I believe it is necessary now
but having had that idea turned down
over and over again to now see it
brought forward in this year's budget
with the previous year's new homes bonus
used to pay off a debt that cannot match
the purchasing power lost
it is painful to see and acknowledge
that the buying power that we had last
year is now reduced by almost 26 percent
potential loss of buying power due to
property inflation that I predicted last
year if we didn't use the new homes
bonus then was 82 350 pounds
that predicted loss based on that sum is
now closer to 139 995 pounds due to
inflation and further property increases
and we have a year behind where we could
be in terms of creating the in-house
temporary accommodation we desperately
need to
this is the history of this proposal
but it has a far brighter future and I
know how well officers have planned and
will continue to plan
and I fully welcome this usage of the
new homes bonus
it is exactly how I would have used it
thank you
thank you councilor Whitehead uh
councilor Saunders would you like to
respond well I don't think there's an
actual question in there but no I don't
think there's a question that counts
thank you councilor Whitehead as usual
you'd depress me with your figures but
be assured that we are aware and I've
already mentioned it this evening it's
one of our priorities and we are looking
at plans we do have plans we can't
actually go public with those plans at
this point in time because there's
commercial sensitivity but be assured
that we do have plans and we will be
bringing forward to this Council
recommendations with regards to
increased availability for our residents
and our homeless families which is the
homeless people that I want to
concentrate most and I know that uh
councilor bayford is of the same opinion
but I thank you for your comments as
usual uh very well prepared and
um yes somewhat depressing you're
absolutely right and no doubt the film
that's now going on General release will
bring even more inflation to the
property prices in Margate so something
to look forward to thank you
thank you very much counselor
next speak under 20.1 I have cancer
Everett
thank you later it's it's a bit like one
room through the Looking Glass isn't it
I mean here we have a conservative
Administration proposing an increase in
the uh Revenue spending budget of 19.6
I'm not sure I ever expected to see that
really
unfortunately it's partly a product of
um inflation which your government is
allowed to run out of control not
entirely through faxes under that they
could determine but certainly I don't
think anybody could claim that over
recent months it's managed the economy
well
and of course the the backdrop to our
budget is always uh the position as that
we're put in by central government and
you can see even in the detail of this
budget things like that you know the
fact we've lost a hundred thousand
pounds
um in terms of property searches because
that's been taken away from us they're
constantly giving us a new series of
challenges to deal with I'm I'm not
going to
um reiterate what councilor Whitehead
said I think we I think we all know the
ironies and the
um the context of that discussion
um there are some good things in this
budget
um I commend the officers who've worked
hard on it there are lots of areas on
which we agree there are always lots of
areas on which we agree
um cross-party all parties on this
Council we tend to focus on the areas in
which we disagree because those are the
things that we have to debate in the
chamber
um and I will say some positive things
about the budget when we get to council
um I'd also like to make this software
the labor group doesn't support the 10
increase in parking charges he doesn't
believe it's about traffic management it
believes it's about funding the budget
we will engage constructively with any
counselors any members of this Council
and any political party in proposals to
offset that charge in terms of this
general fund budget to remove the need
to increase those parking charges by 10
will it will engage with the green party
with councilor Piper's party will engage
with your Administration and will also
engage with your back benches should
they wish to have discussions with us
because some of them may have concerns
about a 10 increase in parking charges
but we'll do so in a in a constructive
way and I'd like to think that working
together as we have throughout this
Council we could reach some consensus
outside of the need for performance in
Council meetings but if we have to go to
the council meeting and have the
performance then unfortunately we will
do that thank you
um so I'm assuming from that that um
what you're saying is that um you're not
going to agree to the 10 so therefore
vote the budget down
um but in in response to that I would
say that
uh even in administration or in
opposition
that
if you take it away from one bit you
have to find it from another so you know
we're quite willing to listen if you
have areas where you think that we could
claw back some percentage of the parking
but we have looked this over and over
and over and through and through and
it's no surprise to you um I don't think
it's any secret that I do have some red
streaks in me somewhere
um so there is a lot of emphasis on the
housing
um because I've made it clear it all
through our Administration that's
something that we do take very seriously
and um
it's uh really down to councilor
Saunders to um to know whether there's
any any wriggle room in any of it we
don't believe that there is a regular
room um and obviously from the 151
officer we can hear as well but uh
we're quite willing to listen if someone
has found some obvious area where we can
take it out of one bit and put it back
into another but um I don't want to
preempt cancer saunders's response and I
think the 151 officer would like to also
come in on this so counselor Saunders
yes thank you
and thank you Council Everett
um I don't quite know what your comment
about the red streak is concerned
certain members of this Council know
that I always wear red socks and
probably got red underwear on at the
moment but there we are
um
[Laughter]
but
but yeah I mean you're absolutely right
leader if we if we take the money away
from one area then we need to find it
elsewhere and quite happy to have debate
on on that subject where we have looked
at it and I will ask the 151 officer to
make comment to see exactly if he
spotted anything that the cabinet
Advisory Group didn't pick up on and if
you can see any as you said leader
wriggle room I don't like I don't like
the word wriggle room but if we've got
some wriggle room there
um yes happy to find it and happy to
adjust as necessary but Chris if you
could comment thank you thank you
counselor
um I just wanted to sort of clarify the
financial impacts of freezing car
parking charges although as sort of
upsets out of my previous
contribution it's more around managing
traffic that's always going to be our
primary concern although we're only
showing a 95 000 pound increase
in income from car parking
um next year that's because it's partly
offsetting a 200 000 pound shortfall in
The Current financial year so the size
of the financial problem with doing that
is actually close to the 300 000. so as
uh the leader rightly said
in order to balance the budget if there
is a proposal to freeze Council car
parking charges or go at a lower level
you're looking to find uh reductions in
expenditure or Savings in the region of
three hundred thousand pounds lots of
the expenditure that's in the budget is
non-negotiable stuff around temporary
accommodation spending for example eight
hundred thousand there's no room to
maneuver on that there's no room to
maneuver around items such as net costs
are borrowing you really will be looking
at taking out some of the items that are
in the budget that are around the
priorities in terms of improvements and
services that we want to deliver for our
residents so it is it's a very difficult
situation if you want to do that but it
certainly is is obviously political
decision setting the budget on something
that can be done but it's certainly not
an easy exercise to undertake as the uh
as as councilor Saunders has said and uh
councilor Ashby the leader said it's a
very long budget setting process we've
gone through this in a lot of detail
there obviously still his time before
the budget is set before
in February but we'd need to come up
with something that's robust and
deliverable to do that in order to sign
the budget setting um process often full
thank you 151
[Music]
um
next to speak under 20.1 is Council
Yates
thank you leader
um
as this item specifically is about the
23 to 24 budget I'm just gonna focus on
this item I think we've made our point
clear on parking
um
um so in general labor welcomes is 23 24
budget and the midterm financial plan uh
again we'd like to thank
um all the officers involved and the
report mentions 19 budget prioritization
meetings and I believe that was done
over two week period
um so thank you for the hard work
involved
from our estimates we believe this
budget addresses an important Point
um which is that TDC needs more
resources in order to serve our
residents
is positive therefore that we are
planning to use the property repair and
maintenance Reserve I'm confident that
members across the room will have ideas
on how this could be spent one item that
jumps out at me is the one functioning
boiler in Winter Gardens which is
keeping the venue free from damp and
mold and this could be uh used as
Council Saunders has said and ensuring
Revenue in the future when it does
reopen but I do digress slightly there
the additional CCTV operatives is one we
fully support and aligns with our
residence survey where 51 of residents
say their top priority in making thanet
a good place to live was feeling safe so
we do support that the addition of a new
climate change coordinator is excellent
and one we fully support given our
carbon neutral Target by 2030. an
additional Economic Development officer
role is to be welcomed given that the
council has administer over 50 million
pounds over the coming years
we welcome the investment into our
future vehicle and Equipment replacement
program and it's great to see the
council confirm the plan to Electrify
the refuse Vehicles by 2030.
as councilor Whitehead has so eloquently
highlighted we do welcome the 2.2
million pounds being put into Capital
program for the further provision of
temporary homelessness
um as you might expect we will be making
suggestions and amendments at the
appropriate time following Council post
school thank you
thank you Council Yates and um thank you
for uh
assuring myself and the cabinet and the
financial team that we've got some
things right and no doubt you and I will
have discussions with regards to the
other elements that you raised thank you
I think we would uh we would Echo a lot
of what has been said we welcome this
budget broadly we think there are some
very good things in it we're really
pleased to see um the building up of
other income streams and the investment
in uh um in infrastructure and property
um we're pleased to note the building up
of Staff teams particularly
um in areas where those additional
members of staff could themselves be
generating Revenue to cover their own
costs and more Economic Development
regeneration indeed climate change where
there are grants available that one
solitary officer trying to do everything
can't possibly be expected to manage so
we're very pleased to see all of those
developments and we're very grateful to
the finance team and two cabinet members
for the time they've put into this and
to Chris and his team for all the
information they've shared the really
helpful seminars Etc it's been really
useful
I think
the main area that I wanted to ask about
and I'm sure I know what the answer is
but the digitization of services
obviously is is the way that we're all
going but we are concerned the sorts of
surveys that we've done with residents
recently highlight this we still have a
high proportion of residents who are not
comfortable with digitized Services who
want to see a face-to-face service who
want to talk to a human being at the end
of a phone line Etc and we just want
some reassurance that those kinds of
services will continue to be provided
for those residents because otherwise we
risk further excluding some of our most
disadvantaged residents thank you
thank you Council Austin
um be assured that we will not
um be overlooking our residents who are
not totally Savvy with digital diet
digitalization
um
and
um I was pleased personally to read in
the newspaper today that cash is making
a comeback because I'm of a maturity
that believes that um cash is
sometimes more important in
um
looking after your own personal budget
then using cards but yeah all your
points are taken on board and uh thank
you for the comments thank you
so this has been moved by councilor
Saunders do I have a seconder councilor
Jill bayford do members agree
so moving on to item seven HRA budget to
introduce councilor David Saunders
thank you leader
next year's HRA budget is underpinned by
a seven percent increase in rents which
is in line with the maximum cap set
nationally by government this equates to
an average rental increase of 6.6 pound
20 per week for our tenants the majority
of which will be covered by increased
housing benefit or Universal Credit
payments to our tenants and I understand
that approximately
um 75 percent of our tenants are in
receipt of said benefits
the HRA has been running at a deficit
for a number of years partly due to the
imposition of statutory rental
reductions and vein caps being placed on
rent increases in recent years the
deficit has been put under further
strain this year due to the high
inflation environment and the consequent
increase in the council's costs as such
this level of proposed rent increases is
needed to continue to drive the HRA to a
balanced and sustainable financial
position and also to finance our
ambitious affordable house building
program and housing investment plan
leader I move the recommendations
thank you Council Saunders speak under
20.1 councilor Whitehead
thank you leader and thank you councilor
Saunders
I would firstly like to thank everyone
involved in HRA planning management and
decisions for the future year
I know from experience that it's not an
easy task and I acknowledge that fully
holding the housing portfolio frequently
means facing extremely difficult
decisions in terms of balancing short
and long-term need
and planning the future of the HRA and
our current stock and the stock we need
to build often falls into the Realms of
the most difficult planning and policy
choices
when we look at rent increases in this
case a seven percent increase this is
especially true
to give context before 2020 rent
increases had been frozen by central
government for all councils
this to a large degree removed the
ability to counteract increases in the
cost of housing provision
which both reduce the ability to
maintain Council stock and forced
residents into the private sector where
rents are far higher and tenancies less
secure
it may have been intended as a way of
reducing Council housing lists and
demand for Council properties to reduce
State involvement in housing overall
but as all of us who live here know
shorter and less secure tenancies and
higher rents do not decrease housing
lists
they increase them
which means that we have an ever-growing
list of residents who should be in
Council housing but are instead often
facing removing themselves from the
housing list and moving to private
accommodation Which is far less
affordable and not I believe what we as
a country or as an area should be
working towards
those who are vulnerable should be
provided for
those who need to cure housing should be
housed
managing that in the current national
climate is difficult and requires
complex decisions
I know this because I was faced with the
need to increase rents to both maintain
and grow our property portfolio in 2020.
at that point at an average increase of
83 Pence per week
I struggled with that decision
and took active measures to mitigate
against it the because even though we
know that these pressures are caused by
a lack of funding at a central level
we have to take as many steps as
possible to minimize the stresses caused
by those Central decisions
in spite of that deliberate mitigation
which effectively protected those whose
increases weren't covered by benefits
the 83 83 Pence increase that was
necessitated wholly by central
government failings was not supported by
the conservative group
and I faced unnecessary political Point
scoring for simply addressing the
realities of the situation
as I have said many times in this
chamber deliberately oppositional
politics often does not reflect the
realities that we are all aware of
bearing in mind that an 83 increase was
not supported we are now being asked to
approve an increase of six pounds 20 per
week
or 322 pounds 40 per year at a far more
challenging time when inflation and
bills have combined to place
extraordinary pressures on individuals
the decision was difficult enough when
it was 83 Pence per week
a seven percent increase at a far more
financially challenging time has to be
addressed even more carefully
for those tenants whose rent is covered
under lha this is potentially less of an
issue as the funding will come directly
from central government in the form of
Universal Credit or housing benefit
but our demographics show that for those
on affordable rent who are often having
to work several jobs or on very low
incomes this could have a significant
impact at a very difficult time
I worried about those tenants
significantly three years ago and as
such put in place a freeze on affordable
rents
removing those on affordable rents from
the increase remove the burden on those
tenants whose rent was not potentially
covered by Central benefits
we are asked to note that roughly three
quarters or 75 percent of our tenants
are accessing housing benefit or
Universal Credit
which in most cases can reduce the
impact of this rise
but conversely that means the 25 of our
tenants or one in four will be affected
by it
considering the scale of this increase I
asked cabinet to consider adopting the
same measure that I did in 2020 to
support those tenants who are not able
to access benefits as although I fully
accept that the precious central
government place on us to both maintain
and create housing stock are
unsustainable
I believe that we also have to consider
what we can do to mitigate those
pressures
and I genuinely believe that considering
the needs of the one in four tenants who
will be affected by this is essential to
safeguard them and remove hardship
thank you
councilor Saunders um no doubt you'll
have to probably take answers from but
we've got both officers here the 151 and
the housing director so I will indeed uh
just like to thank councilor Whitehead
for a comment and once again for the
comprehensive figures that she's
produced
and I will um
go onto YouTube and study the game just
to make sure that I've got it in my own
head but yes it's difficult decisions
that we've had to make I'm afraid
um and
um all credit
um to the officers sitting behind who I
believe may have
um something to contribute to the debate
if I can ask Bob Porter perhaps and also
the 151 officer thank you
thank you thank you councilor Saunders
um
well I think uh a couple of key points
really the first one is that central
government ran consultation about rent
increases this year mindful of the high
inflation position
um and um uh consulted on a range of
options about him yeah what that level
should be and whether this should be a
cap ornament increases for social
housing tenants and that that work
concluded that a
cap of seven percent was would apply
across the sector and and obviously
that's informed the recommendations
within this report I think the second
key point is that the housing revenue
account is running in deficit it's been
running in deficit for a number of years
directly as the question indicates as a
result of the four years of rent
reductions between 2016 and 2020 and
that position is not sustainable in in
the long term we are required to
maintain minimum balances in the housing
revenue account
in in the guidance and in legislation
and we are and that includes the ongoing
maintenance of all of our housing stock
as well as our new build program
um
uh and we do have some significant
programs of investment and work coming
up in our existing stock and obviously
commitments to continue uh with with new
build
um so so clearly as as
Council white and indicates this is a
difficult decision but um you know
ultimately with without a balanced in
long-term balance and sustainable
housing revenue account we can't deliver
that investment
thank you food uh if I can come in after
Mr Porter that thank you counselor
um Mr Porter's covered off many of the
points I was going to make the other
um uh issue I wanted to draw out was
around
um freeze the freezing of um affordable
rents many of our tenants within the
affordable stock will will also be in
receipt of Universal Credit or housing
benefit as well even though it's at a
higher rate what we do in order to
protect those is make sure that we we
cap our affordable rates at the higher
the lha rates or 80 of the private
sector market rate I believe those are
right figures Miss Port correct me if
I'm wrong when we've been looking at the
rental increases that actually meant
they would have been if we applied 10
broadly across all the affordable homes
there would have been 10 properties that
would have gone above the lha rate in in
that case what we've actually done is is
caps those so that they don't go above
it so those properties will actually see
a low were increased lower than seven
percent increase so that they those uh
tenants that are still in affordable
homes
um that are in receipt of benefit will
still only pay at the lha rate so they
should be protected to a
um a greater extent than they would be
without those measures in place
but as Mr Porter said I think as 151 the
fundamental thing for me it's important
that we get the HRA out of deficit
it is running at a deficit it's
important that we get rents back up to
recover the four years of cumulative
rent reduction so there was a four
percent reduction over those four years
when inflation was actually going up
which left quite a big real terms
funding gap between 2016 and
2020 we're still looking to recover that
lost ground if we don't you'll see from
the charts that presented the reports it
leads us in a real position of our
actual balances dipping below that
minimum level and jeopardizing the
investment we need to make in our
housing stock
thank you um Chris and um Bob for for
your info as well
and I think it's it's good to explain
that the overlying
um methodology in the cabinet's mind
behind this budget is to
um make a secure future for this Council
which is to grow
um
on the air or to to concentrate on the
areas that we know that we need to build
for the future I mean this is a
definitely a budget that is building for
the future and always in in these
circumstances I think we've come a long
way from probably the previous years of
budget setting and
this was considered to be the right move
forward to to put us in a good position
going forward this isn't just to get
over this 12 months it is actually
trying to put not only the the HRA in a
position where we can grow the stock but
also the overall structure for for the
council itself so that we can actually
have a sound footing for the future but
I agree with councilor Whitehead that
you know our own housing stock is so
important it's not just to this Council
it is to the whole of the country the
only way this country is going to get
out of its housing situation is for
councils to heavily invest in their own
stock it's the only way forward and
that's not the Socialist in me that is
just pure economic sense that councils
can borrow money cheaper than anywhere
else and if we build our own stock then
we don't have to answer to shareholders
to make profits we can actually build it
and for a lot less than what is expected
of developers to actually produce their
their bills for so it's a win-win as far
as I'm concerned the only the problems
we have in this area is Our Land lack of
land but
if you all the Kent leaders do express
the same things it's regardless of
whether they're a labor Administration
liberal or conservative or whatever it's
we all have coming from the same mindset
so I think the harder we push on that
but it is important that we get our own
house or our own HRA in order and I
think this is the right way forward yes
it is hard but it's going to be hard for
everybody you know private rents
mortgages
um I think mine's gone up quite
considerably as well like everybody else
so but we just got to hope for that it
is the right step forward for the future
so that's the thinking behind the whole
budget process really is to try and
build great foundation for this Council
to go forward so
um I believe you moved this uh item or
do I have a seconder councilor pew
he's secondly do members agree
right last but not least the exciting
item eight which is treasury management
strategy and annual investment strategy
23 24.
over to you cancer Saunders thank you
leader and the shortest of my intros
this report is required in accordance
with the CIP fa code of practice on
Treasury management it covers our
Capital spending and financing plans and
its treasury strategy backed by
Prudential indicators and limits the
report also presents for approval the
council's minimum Revenue provision
policy Capital strategy investment
strategy and non-treasury Investments
report for the next financial year
A draft copy of this report was
considered by the governance and audit
committee on the 30th of November 2022
Leela I moved the cabinet approves the
recommendations thank you
thank you councilor Saunders I always
feel sorry for this item because nobody
ever wants to speak under 20.1 you sure
that no one can just Master something
out to say about it either the report is
so comprehensive and and so well
explained that nobody wants to question
it so congratulations to
to the 151 for that
um so it has been moved and no speakers
and I'll have a second there councilor
carp has uh joined in
so do members agree
thank you members well that concludes
the business for this evening and uh
thank you very much councilor Saunders
you've definitely earned your corn this
evening so um thank you very much I'm
not going to sing an encore I'm just
looking at the pretty uh free-colored
pie chart that we have in that last item
and that's probably
um the reason we've got no comments yeah
absolutely thank you dazzled the hell
out of everybody so um I declare the
meeting closed at